let's be clear though this is beyond
a really really bad infomercial yep okay
it was boring it was awkward it was
disjointed
what's worse is zero substance
nothing we heard no real solutions on
how they will improve the lives of you
the american people no policy
discussions no mention of
the crisis in america's disastrous
democratic-run cities
you know that jerry natto said the myth
that there's violence
a myth no new proposals to compact
covert 19
nothing remember they were missing in
action they thought it was xenophobic
and hysterical to put the travel ban in
effect they were impeaching the
president
uh in the middle of their trial during
the beginnings of all this nowhere to be
found
no mentions of how to make this country
more safe
more secure wealthier prosperous none of
that
all you got was a temper tantrum bumper
stickers slogans about
pretty much how much they hate donald
trump and behind the hatred of him is a
hatred of we smelly walmart shopper
trump supporters irredeemable
deplorables the 15
as biden says you know that the angry
people that
obama talked about that cling to god
guilty
uh yep our second amendment guilty uh
bibles guilty and religion
belief in god guilty again and by the
way they're trying
and i like to save money at walmart my
book is really price low there like
costco's
anyway they're trying to bury the
radical policies that's why
ocasio-cortez gets a minute
andrew cuomo this was a meltdown and
psychosis moment for him
blaming trump for what he's calling the
european
coronavirus wow never mind the thousands
of seniors who died because of
cuomo's disastrous nursing home policy
we have a new report out today as a
matter of fact
andrew from the ap now the true nursing
home death
they quote is clocked in and cloaked in
secrecy they said
could be more than eleven thousand
people not the six
thousand they're saying because of
cuomo's stupid decision then of course
wolf in pennsylvania
uh murphy in new jersey whitmer and we
had our old pal
ohio governor john kasich it's really
just a
really bad case of sore loser itis
kind of like the recent you know
recently deceased john mccain he was
pretty angry about losing
as is hillary clinton and al gore and
mitt romney they all think they're going
to win they don't win they get angry
anyway he delivered john kasich his own
bitter anti-trump rant
and pretty much just recanted everything
that he had said that he publicly
believed in
good luck with that john and then there
was the former first lady michelle obama
praised
by everybody in the mob in the media and
during what were
pretty vindictive and inaccurate and
untrue remarks
she was so busy trashing president trump
it's kind of interesting she didn't even
mention
kamala harris the first female
african-american on a presidential
ticket
although according to reports michelle
obama apparently pre-taped the speech
prior to biden's vp announcement
couldn't be bothered to re-tape it
that's how all in she is for
joe she had almost a full week to tape
it and for the record obama disparaged
republicans all the time
yep the obama administration was very
divisive by the way
his record on the economy 13 million
more americans food stamps 8 million
more poverty lowest labor participation
rates since the 70s
earth's recovery since the 40s and i can
go on it's foreign policy
really bribing mueller's 150 billion in
cash in other currency
both disasters only person who actually
gave any substance at all
got to give credit where it's due aries
comrade bernie sanders bolshevik bernie
member with bernie well he used to be
the an annoyance
on the fringe of the democratic party an
outlier
barely even tolerated everyone there
thought he was a kook
back then many democrats embarrassed by
sanders radical socialist agenda
now well he is the signal caller he's
the leader of the democratic party
he controls the party's agenda he helped
co-write or co-author biden's economic
platform
in other words biden plagiarized it big
portions of it
the bernie biden manifesto as the
president calls it
he is now the mainstream of what is now
the democratic socialist party this is
the most extreme
ticket of any major party in the history
of this country
by the way don't take my word for it
let's just listen to what bernie sanders
had to say last night
he's the leader he's the economic czar
for joe and
kamala take a look our campaign
ended several months ago but our
movement continues
and is getting stronger every day
many of the ideas we fought for that
just a few
years ago were considered radical are
now
mainstream that's actually true
no oil no gas everything's free free
free unless
you pay taxes if you're a taxpayer if
any wealth at all
buckle up this new radical democratic
socialist party they will confiscate
your wealth they will raise trillions of
dollars in taxes
for the false promises that will never
be fulfilled
the socialist utopia and by the way you
can kiss the senate filibuster goodbye
if schumer becomes the leader
chucky nancy they'll be more than happy
to ram this radical wishlist right
through congress
and there is the trojan horse as the
president's referring to joe biden
president he'll sign anything dangerous
agenda
dangerous possibilities but hey at least
bernie sanders
got to give him credit he had energy he
had strength he had stamina
mental alertness mental acuity to
coherently energetically he
gave the most passionate speech last
night now bernie is
a year older than joe biden so the
criticism about biden's struggles like
there was criticism about
reagan and john mccain is not about age
instead it's what we see
every single time joe biden pretty much
opens his mouth
when he dares to venture out of the
basement bunker
today he actually got his decades mixed
up
and years mixed up yet again watch
and uh 40 years later to the month
in january of uh 2000 2018.
uh i found myself in a circumstance
where
uh i'm actually 2012 i found myself
standing in the same spot i had stood 40
years earlier
and i was waiting for a black man tom to
come and pick me up
from philadelphia a guy named barack
obama
on the 17th of january to take me to
washington a trip i've made
a thousand times commuting every day to
be sworn in as president and vice
president
by the way joe let me help you out you
were inaugurated as vice president you
might want to write it down on your
teleprompter
that was 2009 not 2018 and not
2012. glad we got that out of the way
now joe biden has never been a great
speaker
no one has ever really you know been
inspired by a biden
speech but you can go back five years
ago you should see the ad the
rnc put out we'll pull it up later in
the show for you joe then and joe now
um pretty alarming seems frail he seems
weak he seems confused often mixes up
days of the week
often mixes up even the office he's
running for
but it was never this bad now american
people are talking about it democrats i
know are talking about it and even those
few people i know in the media mob
they're all talking about it
the forgetfulness the confusion the
trouble with numbers and dates and
of course these weird bouts with anger
are you are you an addict are you uh
what did he say
um oh did you get a cocaine test huh you
a junkie
come on man now the trump campaign asked
the question that
everyone in america is thinking about
what happened to joe biden
we'll let you decide so you still have
the strength the stamina
does he have the mental alertness and
acuity he once had
you decide so be successful
i sincerely hope some of you become
millionaires and billionaires
i mean that but engage
um you know there's a uh during world
war
ii uh you know where roosevelt came up
with a thing
that you know was totally different than
a than the this call he called the you
know
come on man are you a junkie at this
point joe biden is nothing more than a
vessel for the radical socialist left
they know he can be manipulated and he
will be controlled that's scary
and now all they have to do is get him
across the finish line and hide him as
much as possible
in just 77 short days this country will
either
stay the course the path to prosperity
security
freedom liberty invention innovation
that has made this the richest country
in the world we have advanced the human
condition because of liberty and freedom
or we will risk becoming what is the
next
socialist hell hole choice is going to
be yours america